السلام الله
وبك let down here ‏you guys have enough
lights up there if you need more let us
know we can get some more lights but
just leave the lights please if you have
young children with you make the baby
sitting with you in the
momyy and me room is open just one
last reminder for correcting the people
in the first row there people in the
first row who jobs are dedicated to that
let do is
[Silence]
شاك الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيم اعتدلوا استو سو الصف سد
الخلل cl
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
سبحان الذي اسرى بعبده ليلا من المسجد
الحرام الى المسجد الاقصى الذي باركنا
حوله لنريه من اياتنا انه هو السميع
البصير واتينا موسى الكتاب وجعلناه هدى
لبني
اسرائيل الا
تتخذوا الا تتخذوا من دوني
وكيلا ذريه من حملنا مع نوح
انه كان عبدا
شكورا وقضينا الى بني
اسرائيل في الكتاب
لتفسدن في الارض مرتين
ولتعلن علوا
كبيرا فاذا جاء وعد اولاهما بعثنا عليكم
عبادا لنا اولي باس
شديد بعثنا عليكم عبادا لنا اولي باس شديد
فجاسوا
فجاسوا خلال
الديار وكان
وعدا
مفعولا ثم رددنا لكم الكره عليهم
وامددناكم
باموال
وبنين
وجعلناكم اكثر نفيرا
ان احسنتم
احسنتم
لانفسكم وان اساتم
فلها فاذا
جاء وعد الاخره ليسوءوا
وجوهكم
وليدخلوا المسجد كما دخلوه اول مره
وليتبروا ما علوا تتبيرا
عسى ربكم ان يرحمكم وان عدتم
عدنا
وجعلنا
جهنم
للكافرين
حصيرا الله
اكبر سمع الله
من
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ان هذا القران يهدي للتي هي اقوم ويبشر
المؤمنين
ويبشر المؤمنين الذين يعملون الصالحات ان
ان لهم اجرا
كبيرا وان الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره وان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
اعتدنا لهم عذابا
اليما ويدعوا الانسان بالشر
دعاءه
بالخير وكان
الانسان
عجولا وجعلنا الليل
والنهار
ايتين فمحونا ايه الليل وجعلنا ايه النهار
مبصره لتبتغوا
لتبتغوا
فضلا من ربكم ولتعلموا
تعلموا عدد السنين
والحساب وكل شي وكل
شيء لتعلموا عدد وكل شيء فصلناه
تفصيلا وكل
انسان الزمناه
طائره في عنقه ونخرج له يوم القيامه كتابا
يلق
منشورا اقرا كتابك كفى بنفسك اليوم عليك
حسيبا من اهتدى
فانما يهتدي
لنفسه ومن ضل فانما يضل
عليها ولا تزر
وازره وزر
اخرى وما كنا
معذبين حتى نبعث
رسولا الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
‏per
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذا اردنا ان نهلك قريه امرنا فيها
ففسقوا
فيها ففسقوا فيها فحق عليها القول
فدمرناها
تدميرا وكم اهلكنا من القرون من بعد نوح
وكفى بربك بذنوب عباده خبيرا
بصيرا من كان يريد العاجله عجلنا له فيها
ما نشاء لمن
نريد
ثم جعلنا له جهنم يصلاها مذموما
مدحورا ومن اراد الاخره وسعى لها سعيها
وهو مؤمن
فاولئك كان سعيهم
مشكورا كلا نمد
هؤلاء وهؤلاء
من عطاء
ربك وما كان
عطاء ربك
محظورا انظر كيف فضلنا بعضهم على بعض ولا
الاخره اكبر
درجات واكبر
تفضيلا لا تجعل مع الله ال اخر فتقعد
مذموما
مخذولا وقضى ربك الا تعبدوا الا اياه
وبالوالدين
احسانا اما يبلغن عندك الكبر احدهما او
كلاهما فلا تقل لهما
اف ولا
تنهرهما وقل لهما قولا كريما
واخفض لهما جناح الذل من الرحمه وقل رب
ارحمهما كما ربياني
صغيرا ربكم اعلم بما في
نفوسكم ان تكونوا
صالحين ان تكونوا صالحين فانه كان
للاوابين غفور
وات ذا القربى حقه والمسكين وبنى السبيل
ولا تبذر
تبذيرا
ان المبذرين كانوا اخوان
الشياطين وكان الشيطان لربه
كفورا واما تعرضن عنهم ابتغاء رحمه من ربك
واما تعرضن عنهم
ابتغاء رحمه من ربك ترجوها فقل لهم قولا
ميسورا ولا تجعل يدك مغلوله الى عنقك ولا
تبسطها كل
البسط ولا تبسطها كل البسط فتقعد ملوما
محس س ان ربك يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء
ويقدر انه كان بعباده خبيرا
بصيرا ولا تقتلوا اولادكم خشيه
املاق نحن نرزقهم
واياكم ان قتلهم كان طاا
كبيرا ولا تقربوا
الزنا انه كان
فاحشه وساء
سبيلا ولا تقتلوا النفس التي حرم الله الا
بالحق ومن قتل
مظلوما فقد جعلنا لوليه سلطانا فلا يسرف
في القتل
انه كان
منصورا ولا تقربوا مال اليتيم الا بالتي
هي احسن حتى يبلغ
اشده واوفوا بالعهد
ان العهد كان
مسؤولا واوفوا الكيل اذا كلتم وزنوا
بالقسطاس المستقيم
ذلك
خير واحسن
تاويلا ولا تقف ما ليس لك به علم ان السمع
والبصر والفؤاد كل
اولئك كان عند ربك
مكروها ان ولا تقف ما ليس لك به علم ان
السمع والبصر والفؤاد كل
اولئك كان عنه
مسؤولا ولا تمش في الارض
مرحا انك لن تخرق الارض ولن تبلغ الجبال
طولا كل اولئك كان سيئه عند ربك
مكروها كل كل ذلك كان كل اولئك كان سيئه
عند ربك
مكروها كل كل ذلك كان سيئه عند ربك
مكروها ذلك مما اوحى اليك ربك من
الحكمه ولا تجعل مع الله الى
اخر فتلقى في
جهنم
ملوما
مدحورا الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكب الله
[Silence]
اكب
الله اكب
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين افاصفاكم
ربكم بالبنين واتخذ من
الملائكه
اناثا انكم لتقولون قولا
عظيما ولقد صرفنا للناس في هذا القران من
كل
مثل ولقد صرفنا ولقد صرفنا للناس من كل
مثل
ف ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران من كل مثل
فابى اكثر الناس الا
كفورا واذ قلنا للملائكه
اسجدوا لادم
فسجدوا فسجدوا
الا ابليس قال اسجد لمن خلقت
طينا قال ارايتك هذا الذي كرمت علي لئن
اخرتني الى يوم القيامه
لاحتنكن ذريته الا
قليلا قال اذهب فمن تب عك منهم فان جهنم
جزاؤكم
جزاء
موفورا واستفزز من استطعت منهم بصوتك
واجلب عليهم بخيلك ورجلك
وشاركهم ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران ليذكروا
فابى اكثر الناس الا
كفورا ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران ليذكروا
وما يزيدهم الا
نفورا قل لو كان معه الهه كما يقولون اذا
لابتغوا الى ذي العرش
سبيلا سبحانه وتعالى عما يقولون علوا
كبيرا تسبح له السماوات السبع والارض ومن
فيهن وان من شيء الا يسبح بحمده ولكن لا
تفقهون
تسبيحهم
انه كان حليما
غفورا واذا قرات القران جعلنا بينك وبين
الذي لا يؤمنون كتا حجابا
مستورا واذا قرات القران جعلنا بينك وبين
الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره حجابا
مستورا وجعلنا على قلوبهم اكنه ان يفقهو
هو في اذانهم
وقرا واذا ذكرت رب ك في القران وحده ولوا
على ادبارهم
نفورا نحن اعلم بما يستمعون به اذ يستمعون
اليك واذ هم
نجوى اذ يقول الظالمون ان تتبعون الا رجلا
مسحورا انظر كيف ضربوا لك الامثال فضلوا
فلا
يستطيعون
سبيلا ربكم الذي يزجي لكم الفلك في البحر
لتبتغوا من
فضله وقالوا ائذا ك عظاما ورفاه
اانا
لمبعوثون خلقا
جديدا الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
‏inte
[Silence]
لام
‏don
[Silence]
‏f
‏the
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدلوا
استووا استووا سووا
الصف الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وقالوا ائذا كنا عظاما ورفاه اانا
لمبعوثون خلقا
جديدا قل كونوا حجاره او حديدا او خلقا
مما يكبر في
صدوركم
فسيقولون من
يعيدنا قل الذي فطركم اول مره
فسينغضون اليك رؤوسهم ويقولون متى هو يوم
يدعوكم
فتستجيبون بحمده وتظنون ان لبثتم الا
قليلا وقل لعبادي يقول التي هي
احسن ان الشيطان ينزغ
بينهم ان الشيطان كان للانسان
عدوا
مبينا ربكم ربكم اعلم بكم ان يشا يرحمكم
او ان يشاء
يعذبكم وما ارسلناك عليهم
وكيلا وربك اعلم بمن في السماوات والارض
ولقد فضلنا بعض النبيين على بعض واتينا
داوود
زبورا قل ادعوا الذين زعمتم من دونه فلا
يملكون فلا يملكون كشف الضر عنكم ولا
تحويلا
اولئك الذين يدعون يبتغون الى ربهم
الوسيله
ايهم ايهم اقرب ويرجون رحمته
ويخافون
عذابه ان عذاب ربك كان
محظورا ان عذاب ربك كان
محذورا وان من قريه الا نحن مهلكوها قبل
يوم القيامه او معذبوها عذابا
شديدا كان ذلك في الكتاب مستو
وما منعنا ان نرسل بالايات الا ان كذب بها
الاولون ولقد اتينا ثمود
الناقه
مبصره فظلموا
بها واتينا ثمود الناقه
مبصره فظلموا بها وما نرسل بالايات
الا
تخويفا واذ قلنا لك ان ربك احاط
بالناس وما جعلنا الرؤيا التي اريناك الا
فتنه للناس والشجره الملعونه في
القران ونخوفهم فما يزيدهم الا طغيانا
كبيرا واذ قلنا
للملائكه اسجدوا لادم
فسجدوا فسجدوا الا ابليس قال ااسجد لمن
خلقت
طينا قال ارايتك هذا الذي اخ قال ارايتك
هذا الذي كرمت علي لئن اخرتني الى يوم
القيامه لئن اخرتني الى يوم يوم القيامه
لاحتنكن
ذريته الا
قليلا قال اذهب فمن تبعك منهم فان
جهنم
جزاؤكم فان جهنم
جزاؤكم
جزاء
موفورا واستفزز من استطعت منهم بصوتك
واجلب
عليهم واجلب عليهم بخيلك ورجلك وشاركهم في
الاموال وشاركهم في الاموال
وعدهم وما يعد وشاركهم في الاموال
والاولاد
وعدهم وما
يعدهم وما يعدهم الشيطان الا غرورا
ان عبادي ليس لك عليهم سلطان الا من
اتبعك ان عبادي ليس لك عليهم
سلطان وكفى بربك
وكيلا ربكم الذي يزجي لكم الفلك في البحر
لتبتغوا من فضله
انه كان بكم
رحيما واذا ضل
عنكم واذا مسكم الضر في البحر ضل من تدعون
الا
اياه
فلما نجاكم الى البر
اعرضتم وكان
الانسان
كفورا افامنتم ان يخسف بكم جانب البر او
يرسل عليكم
حاصبا او يرسل عليكم حاصبا
ثم لا تجدوا لكم
وكيلا ام امنتم ان يعيدكم فيه تاره اخرى
فيرسل فيرسل عليكم
قاصفا من
الريح ام امنتم
ان يعيدكم فيه تاره اخرى فيرسل عليكم
قاصفا من الريح
فيغرق
فيغرق بما
كفرتم
ثم لا تجدوا لكم علينا به
تبيعا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد كرمنا بني ادم وحملناهم في البر
والبحر
ورزقناهم
ورزقناهم من الطيبات وفضلناهم على كثير
ممن خلقنا تفضيل
يوم ندعو كل اناس
بامامهم فمن اوتي كتابه بيمينه
فاولئك يقرون كتابهم ولا يظلمون
فتيلا ومن كان في هذه اعمى فهو في الاخره
اعمى واضل
سبيلا وان كادوا ي فنونك عن الذي اوحينا
اليك لتفتري علينا غيره واذا لاتخذوك
خليلا ولو ان ولو
ان فلو لا ان ثبتناك لقد كدت تركن اليهم
شيئا
قليلا ولولا ان ثبتناك لقد كدت تركن اليهم
شيء
قليلا اذا لاذقناك ضعف الحياه وضعف
الممات
ثم لا تجد لك نص علينا
نصيرا وان كادوا ليستفزونك من الارض
ليخرجوك منها واذا لا يلبثون خلافك الا
قليلا سن جه من قد ارسلنا قبلك من
رسلنا ولا تجد
لسنتنا
تحويلا ولا تجد
تحويلا اقم الصلاه لدلوك الشمس الى غسق
الليل وقران الفجر ان قران الفجر كان
مشهود
ومن الليل فتهجد به نافله لك عسى ان يبعثك
ربك
مقاما
محمودا وقل رب ادخلني مدخل صدق واخرجني
مخرج
صدق واجعل لي من لدنك سلطانا
نصيرا وقل جاء الحق وز ق
الباطل
ان الباطل كان
زهوقا وننزل من القران ما هو
شفاء ورحمه
للمؤمنين وما يزيد ولا يزيد الظالمين الا
خسارا واذا انعمنا على الانسان اعرض وناى
بجانبه واذا مسه الشر كان
يؤوسا واذا مسه الشر كان
يؤوسا قل
كل يعمل على
شاكلته فربك فربكم هو فربكم اعلم بمن هو
اهدى
سبيلا
ويسالونك عن الروح
قل الروح من امر ربي وما اوتيتم من العلم
الا
قليلا ولئن شئنا
لنذهبن بالذي اوحينا
اليك
ثم لا تجد لك به علينا
وكيلا الا رحمه من ربك
ان فضله كان عليك
كبيرا قل لئن اجتمعت الانس والجن على ان
ياتوا بمثل هذا
القران لا ياتون بمثله ولو كان بعضهم لبعض
ظهيرا ولقد صرفنا للناس في هذا القران من
كل ما مثل فابى اكثر الناس الا
كفورا وقالوا لن نؤمن لك حتى تفجر لنا من
الارض
ينبوعا او تكون لك
جه من نخيل وعنب فتفجر
الانهار فتفجر الانهار خلالها
تفجيرا او تسقط
السماء كما زعمت علينا
كسفا او تاتي بالله
والملائكه
قبيلا او يكون لك بيت من زخرف او ترقى في
السماء ولن نؤمن لرقيك حتى تنزل علينا
كتابا
نقراه قل سبحان ربي هل كنت الا بشرا
رسولا وما منع الناس ان يؤمنوا اذ
جاءهم الهدى الا ان قالوه الا ان قالوا
ابعث الله بشرا
رسولا قل لو كان في الارض
ملائكه يمشون
مطمئنين اذا لو كان في الارض
مطمئنين
لنزلنا لنزلنا عليهم من
السماء ملكا
رسولا قل كفى بالله شهيدا بيني وبينكم
انه بعباده خبيرا
بصيرا انه بعباده كان خبيرا
بصيرا انه كان بعباده خبيرا
بصيرا ومن يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد لهم
اولياء من دونه ويحشرهم يوم القيامه على
وجوههم عميا
وبكما
وصما ونحشرهم يوم القيامه على وجوههم عميا
وصما ماواهم
جهنم كلما خبت زدناهم
سعيرا ذلك لك
جزاؤهم بانهم كفروا
باياتنا
وقالوا وقالوا ائذا كنا عظاما ورفه اانا
لمبعوثون خلقا
جديدا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه
ومنوه باذن الله تعالى عن ابي هريره رضي
الله عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ما ينتظر احدكم الا غنا متغ او فقرا
منسيا او هما مفس او
مرض او موتا مجهز او الدجال فشر غائب
ينتظر
وساى وامر رواه
الترمذي الحمد
لله الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
اللهانه وتالى
‏able because
[Silence]
ض ‏that makes you incapable you have
desire come to but you able go on own
you require help from other people
because of help it prevents you from
doing goodness and so on and so for and
he ends by saying or such a death that
just comes at you without any without
any warning it just comes to you and
this is why as believers we may take
advantage of the opportunity now opp in
front and not wait for tomorrow is the
poet he say
في الدنيا فانك لا تي فان جن عليك هلل
تعيش ال
الفجر
ض من صم رمضان ايمان واحتسابا غفر له ما
تقدم من
ذنبه احت
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏students
have
[Silence]
ands الله خير وصلب نبينا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه وسلم
[Silence]
الله
استووا
واعتدلوا ب سجده سجده تلاوه ان ذا ست ركعه
ان شاء
الله استرين
الله
اكبر
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اولم يروا ان الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض قادر على ان يخلق مثلهم وجعل لهم
اجلا لا ريب فيه فابى الظالمون الا كفورا
قل لو انتم تملكون خزائن رحمه ربي اذا
لامسكتم خشيه
الانفاق وكان الانسان
قتورا ولقد اتينا موسى تس ايات بينات
فاسال بني
اسرائيل اذ
جاءهم اذ جاءهم فقال فقال فرعون اني لاظنك
يا موسى
مسحورا ولقد اتينا موسى تسع
ايات بينات فاسال بني اسرائيل اذ جاءهم
فقال له فرعون اني لاظنك يا موسى
مسحورا قال لقد علمت ما انزل
هؤلاء الا رب السماوات والارض
بصائر واني
لاظنك يا فرعون
مثبورا فاراد ان
يستفزهم من الارض فاغرقناه ومن معه جميعا
وقلنا من بعده لبني
اسرائيل اسكنوا الارض فاذا جاء وعد الاخره
جئنا بكم
لفيفا وبالحق انزلناه وبالحق نزل وما
ارسلناك الا
مبشرا
ونذيرا
وقرانا فرقناه لتقراه على الناس على مكث
ونزلناه
تنزيلا قل امنوا به او لا
تؤمنوا ان الذين ان الذين اوتوا العلم من
قبله اذا يتلى عليهم يخرون للاذقان
سجدا ويقولون سبحان ربنا ان كان وعد ربنا
لمفعولا
خرون للاذقان يبكون ويزيدهم
خشوعا الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
قل ادعوا الله او ادعوا
الرحمن اياما تدعوا فله الاسماء الحسنى
ولا تجهر بصلاتك ولا تخافت بها وابتغ بين
ذلك
سبيلا وقل الحمد لله الذي لم يتخذ ولدا
ولم يكن له شريك في الملك ولم يكن له ولي
من الذل وكبر
تكبيرا الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله الذي انزل على عبده
الكتاب ولم يجعل له عوجا قيما لينذر باسا
شديدا من لدنه ويبشر المؤمنين الذين
يعملون الصالحات ان لهم اجرا حسنا
ماكثين فيه ابدا
وينذر الذين قالوا اتخذ الله
ولدا ما لهم به من علم ولا
لابائهم ما لهم به من علم ولا
لابائهم كبرت كلمه تخرج من افواههم ان
يقولون الا كذبا فلعلك باخع نفسك على
اثارهم ان لم يؤمنوا بهذا الحديث اسفا انا
جعلنا ما على الارض زينه لها لنبلوهم ايهم
احسن عملا وانا لجاعلون ما عليها
صعيدا
جرزا ام حسبت ان اصحاب الكهف والرقيم
كانوا من اياتنا عجبا اذ او الفتيه الى
الكهف فقالوا ربنا اتنا من لدنك رحمه وهيئ
لنا من امرنا
رشدا فضربنا على اذانهم في الكهف سنين
عددا ثم بعثناهم لنعلم اي الحزبين احصى
لما لبثوا امدا نحن نقص عليك نباهم بالحق
انهم فتيه امنوا بربهم وزدناهم هدى وربطنا
على قلوبهم اذ قاموا فقالوا ربنا رب
السماوات والارض لن ندعو من دونه
الها لن ندعو من دونه الها لقد قلنا اذا
شططا
هؤلاء قومنا اتخذوا من دون
الهه لولا ياتون عليهم
بسلطان بين فمن اظلم ممن افترى على الله
كذبا واذ اعتزلتموهم وما يعبد واذ
اعتزلتموهم وما يدعون من دون الله فاوا
الى الكهف ينشر لكم ربكم من رحمته
واذ اعتزلتموهم وما يعبدون من دون الله
فاوا الى الكهف
ينشر لكم ربكم من رحمته ويهيئ لكم من
امركم
مرفقا واذ اعتزلتموهم وما يعبدون الا الله
فاو الى الكهف ينشر لكم ربكم من
رحمته يهيئ لكم من امركم مرفقا وترى الشمس
اذا طلعت تزاور عن كهفهم ذات اليمين واذا
غربت تقرضهم ذات الشمال وهم في
فجوه منه ذلك من ايات
الله من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا وتحسبهم ايقاظا وهم رقود ونقلبهم
ذات اليمين وذات الشمال وكلبهم باسط
ذراعيه
بالوصيد لو اطلعت عليهم لوليت منهم فرارا
ولملئت منهم
رعبا وكذلك بعثناهم ليتساءلوا بينهم
وكذلك بعثناهم
ليتساءلوا بينهم قال قائل منهم كم لبثتم
قالوا لبثنا يوما او بعض يوم قالوا ربكم
اعلم بما لبثتم فابعثوا احدكم بورقكم هذه
الى المدينه
فلينظر
فلينظر ايها ازكى طعاما فليات
برزق منه وليتلطف
وليتلطف ولا يشعرن بكم احدا انهم ان
يظهروا عليكم يرجموكم او يعيدوكم في
ملهم
ولن تفلحوا اذا
ابدا وكذلك اعثرنا عليهم ليعلموا ان وعد
الله حق وان الساعه لا ريب
فيها وكذلك اعثرنا عليهم ليعلموا ان وكذلك
اعثرنا عليهم ليعلموا ان وعد الله حق وان
الساعه لا ريب فيها اذ يتنازعون بينهم
امرهم اذ يتنازعون بينهم امرهم فقالوا
ابنوا عليهم بنيانا ربهم اعلم بهم قال
الذين غلبوا على امرهم
لنتخذن عليهم
مسجدا سيقولون ثلاثه رابعهم كلبهم ويقولون
خمسه سادسهم كلبهم
رجما
بالغيب ويقولون سبعه وثامنهم كلبهم قل ربي
اعلم بعد تهم ما يعلمهم الا قليل فلا تمار
فيهم الا
مراء ظاهرا ولا تستفت فيهم منهم احدا ولا
تقولن لشيء اني فاعل ذلك غدا الا ان يشاء
الله واذكر ربك اذا نسيت وقل عسى ان
يهديني ربي لاقرب من هذا رشدا ولبثوا في
كهفهم
00 سنين وازدادوا
تسعا قل الله اعلم بما لبثوا له غيب
السماوات والارض ابصر به
واسمع ما لهم من دونه من ولي ولا يشرك في
حكمه
احدا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واتل ما اوحي اليك من كتاب ربك لا مبدل
لكلماته ولن تجد من دونه
ملتحدا واصبر نفسك مع الذين يدعون ربهم
بالغداه والعشي يريدون
وجهه ولا تعد عنهم تريد زينه الحياه
الدنيا ولا تطع من اغفلنا قلبه عن ذكرنا
واتبع هواه وكان امره
فرطا وقل الحق من ربكم فمن شاء فليؤمن ومن
شاء
فليكفر انا اعتدنا للظالمين نارا احاط بهم
سرادق
وان يستغيثوا يغاثوا
بماء كالمهل يشوي
الوجوه بئس الشراب وساءت
مرتفقا ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
انا لا نضيع اجر من احسن عملا اولئك لهم
جنات عدن تجري من تحتهم الانهار
يحلون فيها من ذهب
ويلبسون ويلبسون ثيابا خضرا من سندس
واستبرق
يحلون فيها من اساور من ذهب ويلبسون ثيابا
خضرا من
سندس واستبرق
متكئين فيها على
الارائك نعم الثواب وحسنت مرتفق
واضرب لهم مثلا الرجلين جعلنا لاحدهما
جنتين من اعناب وحففناهما
بنخل وجعلنا بينهما زرعا كلت
الجنتين اتت اكلها ولم تظلم منه شيئا
وفجرنا خلالهما
نهرا وكان له ثمر فقال لصاحب به وهو
يحاوره انا اكثر منك مالا واعز نثرا ودخل
جنته وهو ظالم لنفسه قال ما اظن ان تبيد
هذه ابدا وما اظن الساعه
قائمه ولئن رددت الى ربي لاجدن خيرا منها
منقلبا
قال له صاحبه وهو يحاوره اكفرت بالذي خلقك
من تراب ثم من نطفه ثم من نطفه ثم سواك
رجلا لكن هو الله ربي ولا اشرك بربي احدا
ولولا اذ دخلت جنتك قلت ما شاء الله لا
قوه الا
بالله ان ترني انا اقل منك مالا وولدا
فعسى ربي ان يؤتيني خيرا من جنتك ويرسل
عليها حسبانا من السماء فتصبح صعيدا
زلقا او يصبح ماؤها غورا فلن تستطيع له
طلبا يط
بثمره فاصبح يقلب كفيه على ما انفق فيها
وهي خاويه على عروشها ويقول ويقول يا
ليتني لم اشرك بربي احدا ولم تكن له فئه
ينصرونه من دون الله وما كان
منتصرا هنالك الولايه لله الحق هو خير
ثوابا وخير
عقبا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ا
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين واضرب لهم مثل الحياه الدنيا كما ان
انزلناه من السماء فاختلط به نبات الارض
فاصبح هشيما تذروه
الرياح وكان الله على كل شيء
مقتدرا المال البنون زينه الحياه الدنيا
والباقيات الصالحات خير عند ربك ثوابا
وخير
املا ويوم نسير الجبال وترى الارض بارزه
وحشرناهم فلم نغادر منهم احدا وعرضوا على
ربك صفا لقد جئتمونا كما خلقناكم اول مره
بل زعمتم ان لن نجعل لكم
موعدا ووضع الكتاب فترى المجرمين مشفقين
مما فيه
ويقولون ويقولون يا ويلتنا ما لهذا الكتاب
لا يغادر
صغيره ولا كبيره الا
احصاها ووجدوا ما عملوا حاضرا ولا يظلم
ربك احد
واذ قلنا
للملائكه اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا ابليس
كان من الجن ففسق عن امر
ربه افتتخذونه
وذريته
اولياء من دوني وهم لكم
عدو بئس للظالمين بدلا ما اشهدتهم خلق
السماوات والارض ولا خلق انفسهم وما كنت
متخذ المضلين
عضدا ويوم يقول نادوا
شركائي الذين زعمتم فدعوهم فلم يستجيبوا
لهم وجعلنا بينهم
موبقا وراى المجرمون النار فظنوا انهم
مواقعوها ولم يجدوا عنها مصرفا
ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران للناس من كل مثل
وكان الانسان اكثر شيء
جدلا وما منع الناس ان يؤمنوا اذ جاءهم
الهدى ويستغفروا ربهم الا ان تاتيهم سنه
الاولين او ياتيهم العذاب
قبلا و نرسل المرسلين الا مبشرين
ومنذرين ويجادل الذين كفروا بالباطل
ليدحضوا به الحق واتخذوا اياتي وما
انذروا
هزوا ومن اظلم
من واتخذوا اياتي وما انذروا هزوا
ومن اظلم ممن ذكر بايات ربه فاعرض عنها
ونسي ما قدمت
يداه انا جعلنا على قلوبهم
اكنه ان يفقهوا هوفي اذانهم
وقرا وان تدعهم الى الهدى فلن يهتدوا اذا
ابدا وربك الغفور ذو الرحمه لو يؤخذ هم
بما كسبوا لعجل لهم
العذاب بل لهم موعد لن يجدوا من دونه
موئلا وتلك القرى اهلكناهم لما ظلموا
وجعلنا لمهلكهم
موعدا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واذ قال موسى لفتاه لا ابرح حتى ابلغ مجمع
البحرين او امضي
حقبا فلما بلغا مجمع بينهما نسيا حوتهما
فاتخذ سبيله في البحر
سربا فلما جاوزا قال لفتاه اتنا
غداءنا لقد لقينا من سفرنا هذا
نصبا قال ارايت اذ اوينا الى الصخره فاني
نسيت الحوت وما انسانيه الا الشيطان ان
اذكره واتخذ سبيله في البحر
عجبا قال ذلك ما كنا نبغ فارتد على
اثارهما قصصا فوجد عبدا من عبادنا اتيناه
رحمه من عندنا وعلمناه من لدنا
علما قال له موسى هل اتبعك على ان تعلمني
مما علمت
رشدا قال انك لن تستطيع معي صبرا وكيف
تصبر على ما لم تحط به خبرا قال ستجدني ان
شاء الله صابرا ولا اعصي لك
امرا قال فان اتبعتني فلا تسالني عن شيء
حتى احدث لك منه ذكرا فانطلقا حتى اذا
ركبا في السفينه
خرقها قال اخرقتها لتغرق اهلها لقد جئت
شيئا امرا قال الم اقل انك لن تستطيع معي
صبرا قال لا تؤاخذ ذني بما نسيت ولا
ترهقني من امري
عسرا فانطلق حتى اذا لقيا غلاما
فقتله قال اقتلت نفسا
زكيه بغير نفس لقد جئت شيئا
نكرا قال الم اقل لك انك لن تستطيع معي
صبرا قال ان سالتك عن شيء
بعدها فلا
تصاحبني قد بلغت من لدني
عذرا فانطلق حتى اذا اتيا اهل قريه
استطعما اهلها فابوا ان
يضيفوهما فوجدا فيها جدارا يريد ان ينقض
فاقامه قال لو شئت لاتخذت عليه اجرا قال
هذا فراق بيني وبينك سانبئك بتاويل ما لم
تستطع عليه
صبرا اما السفينه فكانت لمساكين يعملون في
البحر فاردت ان
اعيبها وكان
وراءهم ملك ياخذ كل سفينه
غصبا واما الغلام فكان ابواه مؤمنين
فخشينا ان يرهقهما طغيانا وكفرا فاردنا ان
يبدلهما ربهما خيرا منه زكاه واقرب رحما
واما الجدار فكان لغلامين يتيمين في
المدينه وكان تحته
كنز
لهما وكان ابوهما صالحا
فاراد ربك ان يبلغا اشدهما ويستخرجا
كنزهما رحمه من ربك وما فعلته عن امري ذلك
تاويل ما لم تسطع عليه
صبرا
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الشفع والوتر ان شاء الله استووا
واستقيموا اعتدلوا
[Silence]
تراصوا الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى
والذي اخرج
المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا ت ان سى الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى
النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا ل في الصحف
الاولى صحف صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
ده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل
يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما
عبدتم
ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
‏s
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم ص راط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله
الصمد لم لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم لك الحمد الحمد حتى ترضى ولك
الحمد اذا رضيت ولك الحمد بعد الرضا ولك
الحمد على كل حال لك الحمد انت قيوم
السماوات والارض ومن فيهن ولك الحمد انت
نور السماوات والارض ومن فيهن لك الحمد لا
اله الا انت اللهم اهدنا فيم هديت وعافنا
في من عافيت وتولنا فيمن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف
عنا شر ما قضيت انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت لك الحمد لك الحمد لا اله الا انت
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين
معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به
جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب
الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما
ابقيت واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على
من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في
ديننا ولا تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا
ولا الى النار مصيرنا واجعل اللهم الجنه
هي دارنا
وقرارنا اللهم لك الحمد على الاسلام اللهم
لك الحمد على الاسلام اللهم فتوفنا مسلمين
اللهم فتوفنا مسلمين اللهم واعتق رقابنا
من
النار اللهم واعتق رقابنا من
النار سبحانك ربنا رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
سبحان ‏ja